I'm Cory Cleveland currently a senior I  study Electrical Engineering and I am  the captain of the ballroom dance team  this year okay  I started off when I was a freshman and  it was completely new to me I'd never  done any dancing  I just call them like flying across the  floor you know like it was hard not to  get infected I was like I want to be  able to do this and prevent this myself  as well as give this to other people  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  you  [Music]  it's amazing because humans have like  this small imperceptible ability to pick  up on each other's body language and so  I can talk to the audience from that way  even more so I have an opportunity to  communicate with my partner and this is  like such an intimate and deep  connection with another person and  that's really what I enjoy  [Music]